Waiting for more John Wick? Missing the Marvel
Universe? Or maybe you're after something new?
Either way, Hollywood has got you covered — and it
looks like 2024 is going to be a heck of a year for film.
Sony's Spider-Man universe is ready to re-open
in 2024 with the release of the weirder, wilder,
and woman-centric spin-off, Madame Web. Based
on a somewhat obscure Marvel Comics character,
the film will introduce audiences
to mystical oracle Cassandra Webb,
an elderly ally of the webbed wall-crawler
who uses her powers of clairvoyance to see
into his future. With her unique and
surprising psychic powers, Webb isn't
the kind of action-oriented hero you might expect
to see carry their own big-budget feature film.
To that end, it seems that Sony has made some
significant changes to the character for the
upcoming movie, including casting a young
actor, Dakota Johnson, in the title role.
Madame Web will be joined by quite a talented
cast, featuring stars such as Sydney Sweeney,
Celeste O'Connor, and Adam Scott. Sweeney was
recently confirmed to be playing Julia Carpenter,
an early iteration of Spider-Woman, in
the character's live-action debut. Indeed,
the film is expected to see a team-up of
various Spider-Women drawn from the comics.
Though little is known about the plot at
this stage, Sony will no doubt be hoping
for another success like Tom Hardy's Venom when
Madame Web lands in theaters on February 16th,
2024. The worst case scenario, we'd
imagine, looks a little something like this.
"Intriguing."
It's no easy task to go even bigger than the
blockbuster crossover Godzilla vs. Kong, but
the sequel, Godzilla x Kong: The New Empire, is
going to give it a shot. The previous film faced
a mighty challenge back in 2021, as it released
to theaters and on HBO Max simultaneously due to
the ongoing COVID-19 pandemic; nevertheless, it
managed to net an impressive $470 million. With
theaters once again a big attraction these
days, the sequel stands to fare much better.
Godzilla x Kong: The New Empire will see the
return of Rebecca Hall as Dr. Ilene Andrews
and Brian Tyree Henry as Bernie Hayes, while
Legion star Dan Stevens joins the franchise
in an as-yet undisclosed role. But while the
first film depicted the epic battle between
two titanic terrors, The New Empire will flip the
script. Picking up where the last film left off,
Kong and Godzilla are now reluctant allies —
and the sequel will see the two beasts team
up to take on a new menace. The New Empire
is set to be released on March 15th, 2024.
Disney's live-action remakes have been hit or
miss to say the least, but that hasn't slowed
the studio down one bit. In 2024, they're going to
tackle a classic, releasing a live-action version
of Snow White and the Seven Dwarfs, one of the
most beloved animated films of all time. If Disney
is going to do it justice, they'll need a roster
of the industry's best talent to bring it to life;
Academy Award nominee Greta Gerwig has been hired
to pen the script, while The Amazing Spider-Man's
Marc Webb is set to direct. Rachel Zegler of
West Side Story fame takes on the title role,
while Gal Gadot trades in her heroic
tiara for a crown to play the Evil Queen.
Disney has truncated the movie's title to
the simpler Snow White, and they're also
planning to update the classic story for modern
audiences. The essence remains the same, however:
Like the original, Snow White will follow a
young princess who is pursued by a vile queen
and aided by seven hospitable dwarves. Will
Snow White be able to recapture the magic and
meet with acclaim like Jon Favreau's The
Jungle Book? Or will it land with a thud
like… pretty much all of the others? We'll find
out when the film arrives on March 22nd, 2024.
After Ryan Reynolds all but forced Fox to push
the start button on the Deadpool franchise,
the Merc with the Mouth churned out two massive
money-making hits. But questions immediately arose
when the studio was gobbled up by Disney: Would
Marvel want the foul-mouthed, R-rated Deadpool
films integrated into their family-friendly MCU?
Those concerns were put to bed in early 2021 by
Marvel's head honcho Kevin Feige, who declared
that there would indeed be a third Deadpool movie,
and that it would retain its harsh rating,
glorious violence, and dark sense of humor.
But fans were in for one more surprise. When the
film was officially announced the following year,
Reynolds revealed that Hugh Jackman
would be joining him for the threequel,
reprising his role as Wolverine — a return
he'd previously sworn off. We don't know much
about the plot of Deadpool 3, although it's
likely the film will depict an epic clash
(and eventual team-up) between Wade Wilson
and Logan. Adam Project's Shawn Levy will
be directing, and a number of cast members
from Deadpool and Deadpool 2 will return too,
including Morena Baccarin, Stefan Kapicic,
Brianna Hildebrand, and even Rob Delaney.
"Never underestimate a man with a
mustache. Just ask anyone in Brooklyn.
You're a goddamn superhero, you!"
"X-Force!"
The cast also includes Emma Corrin
and Matthew Macfadyen in unannounced
roles. Deadpool 3 hits theaters on May 3rd, 2024.
John Wick is one of the modern day's
hottest movie series, and in 2024,
the franchise brings us the second of two
upcoming spin-off projects: Ballerina. Set
between the third and fourth John Wick films,
Ballerina stars Ana de Armas as a deadly assassin,
with Keanu Reeves due to return in an extended
cameo role. Other actors scheduled to return,
in some capacity or another, include Anjelica
Huston as the Director, Ian McShane as Winston,
and Lance Reddick as Charon, in of
the late star's final performances.
Len Wiseman, who helmed the 2012 remake of Total
Recall, is taking directorial duties on Ballerina,
while Emerald Fennell, writer-director of
Promising Young Woman, joined Shay Hatten
to work on the script. Though not much has
been released regarding the film's story,
Ballerina stands to be another first-rate
action thriller, and, if the John Wick films
are anything to go by, it'll no doubt blow
fans away when it releases on June 7th, 2024.
Pixar is known for founding wildly popular
franchises such as Toy Story and Cars, and,
in 2024, they'll add another to its ranks with
Inside Out 2. The first film in the series came
out all the way back in 2015, and while the
kids who saw it in theaters may have grown up,
the sequel stands to bring in a whole new
generation of viewers. Written and directed
by Pixar veteran Pete Docter, the first Inside
Out centers around a young girl named Riley,
whose emotions manifest as characters inside
her head. The movie was a monster hit,
amassing more than $800 million
dollars at the box office.
Thus far, Amy Poehler is one of the few cast
members officially announced for the sequel;
she'll reprise the role of Joy. Actor
Mindy Kaling, who voiced Disgust,
has revealed that she is not involved, with
rumors swirling about contract negotiations
breaking down over a salary dispute. Bill Hader,
who played Fear, will not be coming back, either,
but Lewis Black and Phyllis Smith, who play Anger
and Sadness respectively, are expected to return.
As for the plot? Well, Poehler has
revealed that the film will pick
up with Riley as she deals with the
emotional changes of adolescence.
"Hey, guys — what's puberty?"
"I dunno. Probably not important."
But we'll have to wait for June 14th,
2024 to see how it all goes down.
Disney's live-action Lion King movie
proved divisive among fans and critics,
with many feeling the shot-for-shot remake was a
wholly unnecessary endeavor. But the box office
doesn't lie: The Lion King made over $1 billion
dollars in theaters, making it quite clear there's
a huge appetite for more adventures at Pride Rock.
Thus, in 2024, Disney will release a prequel,
Mufasa: The Lion King. If Beale Street Could
Talk director Barry Jenkins replaces Jon
Favreau behind the camera, while Aaron Pierre
will step in as the voice of a younger Mufasa.
Returning cast members for the prequel include
Billy Eichner and Seth Rogen as Timon and Pumbaa,
as well as John Kani as Rafiki. Kelvin Harrison
Jr. will voice the younger Scar. Once again,
Disney will use life-like CGI animation
to recreate the stunning photorealistic
world of The Lion King, this time
for a story that explores Mufasa's
youth. Disney has so far revealed that
a devastating flood leaves him orphaned,
to be adopted by another pride. Battling against
the odds, this ordinary outsider will rise
up to take his place as the king of the
jungle — and it'll happen on July 5th, 2024.
The second animated sequel to drop in the
summer of 2024, Despicable Me 4 comes seven
years after the third installment, but just two
years after the second Minions spin-off film,
which told the origin of the film's
anti-hero Gru. In this installment,
Gru is back, once again voiced by Steve Carell,
while Kristen Wiig returns as Lucy, Gru's
wife and an agent of the Anti-Villain League.
The little yellow Minions you — or, at least,
your kids — love will be back too, played by
voice actor Pierre Coffin. What will they be up
to? Well, the details are sketchy at this point,
but what we do know is that the fourth film will
begin shortly after the events of Despicable Me 3,
and will follow Gru, his family, and his
Minions, as they hunt bad guys for the
Anti-Villain League. So far, Illumination has
kept quiet regarding the plot's exact details,
which we probably won't learn more about before
the first trailer releases. But there may be a
wait for the first footage, as the film's
ultimate release is still fairly far away;
Despicable Me 4 is scheduled for July 3rd, 2024.
[cheering]
Based on the novel by A.M. Shine, The Watchers
is a supernatural thriller whose director,
Ishana Shyamalan, has been making a few
waves recently. The daughter of legendary
director M. Night Shyamalan, Ishana cut
her teeth as second unit director on her
father's movie Old. She also worked as a
producer, writer, and director on the Apple
TV+ series Servant. The Watchers will be her
big screen debut when it premieres in 2024.
The novel tells the story of Mina,
a woman who becomes lost in an Irish
forest and struggles to survive
while being hunted by strange,
otherworldly monsters. In this film version of the
story, actress Dakota Fanning will star as Mina,
while Georgina Campbell has been
cast in a leading role alongside her.
Adapted to film by Ishana
Shyamalan and A.M. Shine,
the script became the subject of a minor
bidding war among rival studios — in the end,
New Line Cinema won out. Though not yet
in production, The Watchers is due to
begin filming later this year, with a
planned release date of June 7th, 2024.
M. Night Shyamalan films are fairly divisive,
but the director's willingness to take big
swings on unique projects always makes them
must-watch experiences. That's especially true
now that he's focused himself on making smaller,
stranger titles, such as The Visit and Old.
Whether you loved these movies or hated them,
they certainly got people talking. That's
what makes Shyamalan special — he's always
bringing something fresh to a cinematic
landscape dominated by familiar brand names.
And he's not done yet. In 2023, Shyamalan
faced the apocalypse with Knock at the Cabin,
and in 2024, he'll be leading us straight into
Trap, which is set for release on August 2nd,
2024. Other than that, we don't know much about
it. Will it be an original Shyamalan script?
Will it be adapted from a previous work? Will it
feature any big names that the director worked
with before? We're not sure. The only other bit
of info we know at the moment is that Trap will
be the first film in a multi-year first-look
deal Shyamalan signed with Warner Bros.,
meaning the director is finally leaving
Universal, his long-time studio home.
If you're looking for a studio with a
consistent track record of first-rate
horror movies and thrillers, it's harder
to find better than Blumhouse. Since 2010,
they've been responsible for some of the
most popular and critically-acclaimed horror
films around. They've also been a showcase for
up-and-coming directors, courtesy of hits such
as James Wan's Insidious, Jordan Peele's Get
Out, and Leigh Whannell's The Invisible Man.
"You think you're learning how to beat me,
so I'm gonna truly teach you something."
So, naturally, the studio's upcoming suspense
story, Speak No Evil, is also bound to be a hit.
A remake of a 2022 Danish film of the same
name, Speak No Evil is helmed by Woman in
Black director James Watkins and will star James
McAvoy, whose performance in Blumhouse's Split and
Glass earned him critical acclaim. The Danish
original follows Bjorn and Louise, a couple
who are invited to spend a holiday with Patrick,
Karin, and their son Abel, after meeting them on
vacation in Tuscany. Planned as a pleasant weekend
in a remote village in the Netherlands, Bjorn
and Louise's getaway spirals out of control when
their hosts begin exhibiting disturbing behavior.
McAvoy will feature in the film alongside Scoot
McNairy and Mackenzie Davis, of Terminator:
Dark Fate fame. The film is currently
scheduled to hit theaters on August 9th, 2024.
There are few films more iconic to the goth
crowd than Beetlejuice, the 1988 absurdist
black comedy from director Tim Burton. The
film starred Winona Ryder as Lydia Deetz,
a morose teen who moves into a new home and meets
the ghosts of married couple Barbara and Adam,
as well as a sass-talking trickster from the
underworld named Beetlejuice. Strange, surreal,
and entirely one-of-a-kind, the film made Tim
Burton one of Hollywood's hottest directors
and helped solidify both Ryder and Michael
Keaton as stars. And while all attempts to
get a sequel off the ground have failed thus far,
it looks like we're finally getting one in 2024.
Announced in May 2023, Beetlejuice 2 is finally a
go, and it already has its leading lady attached:
Jenna Ortega, who more than proved her goth
credentials in Netflix's Wednesday. It looks
like Winona Ryder is coming back as Lydia
Deetz too, presumably the mother of Ortega's
new character. She'll be joined by Catherine
O'Hara as Delia Deetz and Monica Bellucci as
Beetlejuice's wife. Justin Theroux will
play an unknown part, and screen legend
Willem Dafoe appears to be playing some sort of
afterlife law enforcement officer. And of course,
you can't make a Beetlejuice movie
without Michael Keaton — luckily,
the Oscar-nominated star is indeed
returning as the ghost with the most.
"It's showtime."
Wednesday scribes Miles Millar and Alfred
Gough are writing the script, while Burton
himself is expected to direct. Beetlejuice 2
will arrive in theaters on September 6th, 2024.
Despite suffering a steady decline in box office
takings, Paramount continues to forge ahead with
the Transformers movie franchise. Hot on the
heels of Transformers: Rise of the Beasts,
the studio is set to return the series
to its animated roots. Transformers One,
a fully animated feature film, explores the
origins of the Autobots and Decepticons on
Cybertron long before the events
of the 2007 blockbuster series.
Revolving around the unlikely friendship
between Optimus Prime and Megatron,
this movie will chronicle their journey to
becoming bitter rivals and deadly enemies.
The voice cast is impressive, with a group of
A-list superstars lending their talents to the
cartoon prequel, including Chris
Hemsworth and Bryan Tyree Henry.
Toy Story 4 filmmaker Josh Cooley directs the
movie, while Steven Spielberg once again serves as
producer. Transformers fans can expect to see the
movie roll out in cinemas on September 13th, 2024.
Many fans believe that the third installment in
a superhero trilogy tends to be the worst. It
certainly rings true for the X-Men trilogy,
Sam Raimi's Spider-Man movies, and Blade:
Trinity — although recent threequels such as
Captain America: Civil War and Spider-Man:
No Way Home appear to have broken the curse. In
2024, Sony is hoping to continue that positive
trend with a third Venom film, currently
scheduled for July 2024, in a rare move
of the studios announcing a sooner release date
than the original announcement for October 2024 .
Tom Hardy will be back in the title role,
of course, while Doctor Strange's Chiwetel
Ejiofor has been cast in an undisclosed part,
and Emmy-nominated Ted Lasso star Juno Temple
has joined the cast as well. And while Andy
Serkis impressed behind the director's chair
in the second film, screenwriter Kelly Marcel
will take the helm for this one. Marcel,
who wrote the first two movies, is also penning
the script, based on a story she developed with
Hardy. Little is known about the plot of the
third movie, but after the conclusion of the
previous film, there are plenty of dangling plot
threads to follow. That said, given Tom Holland's
recent announcement that he's about to take a
break from acting, it's unlikely we'll see his
Peter Parker taking on Eddie Brock just yet
— despite the tease in Let There Be Carnage.
Still, considering the billion-dollar gross
of the first two films and overwhelmingly
positive reviews from fans, expectations
are high for the next movie to deliver even
more spine-tingling thrills, over-the-top spills,
and gut-busting kills. Only time will tell
whether the threequel curse is truly broken.
It's rare to see a sequel to a best picture
Oscar-winner, let alone a legacy sequel
decades later, but that's exactly what
we're getting in 2024 when Ridley Scott
returns to direct Gladiator 2. The original,
released in 2000, won five Academy Awards,
quickly cementing its reputation as a bona
fide classic. This is another chance for Scott
to return to one of his classic franchises as
director but Gladiator 2 will see a mostly-new
cast of characters populate a story that
takes place in a very different world.
"Are you not entertained?!"
Paul Mescal, who earned an Oscar nomination for
his work in Aftersun, stars as the lead character:
a grown-up Lucius, the young boy portrayed
by Spencer Treat Clark in the original film.
Connie Nielsen will be returning as Lucius'
mother, Lucilla, daughter of the late Emperor
Marcus Aurelius. They will be joined by an
all-star cast that includes May Calamawy,
Denzel Washington, Pedro Pascal, Barry
Keoghan, and Derek Jacobi. Meanwhile,
David Scarpa has penned the script. Gladiator
2 is scheduled for November 22nd, 2024.
After years of stops, starts, and missed release
dates, a feature film adaptation of Wicked is
finally on the way. This vision of L. Frank Baum's
Oz reimagines Elphaba, the Wicked Witch of the
West, as a sympathetic protagonist. Her story is
told through an array of vibrant musical numbers
that have become enormously popular with theater
kids and audiences alike. Given that ubiquity,
it's no surprise that the general public is so
hotly anticipating a movie version of Wicked.
This adaptation is directed by Jon M. Chu,
who proved his musical chops helming In
the Heights movie, while Cynthia Erivo of
Harriet and pop star Ariana Grande headline
a star-studded ensemble cast as Elphaba and
Glinda, respectively. They'll be joined here
by the Oscar-winning Michelle Yeoh as Madame
Morrible and Jeff Goldblum as the Wizard of Oz.
With a lead cast like that, there's no
question that the beloved musical numbers
in Wicked will be delivered with plenty
of gusto and energy. Fans can get excited
about the potential for memorable imagery
in Chu's vibrant visual sensibilities,
too. It's taken countless years of nervous
anticipation, but the first installment in the
two-part Wicked movie series is finally going
to arrive in theaters on November 27th, 2024.
Video game adaptations used to be known
as a dud genre. Thanks in no small part
to Sonic the Hedgehog, however, they're
now hotter than ever. One of the last
blockbusters to release before the
COVID-19 pandemic struck in 2020,
the first Sonic film took in $319 million at
the global box office. Its sequel performed
even better. Sonic the Hedgehog 2 introduced
the villain Knuckles, voiced by Idris Elba,
who is due for his own spin-off TV series on
Paramount+. And the movie franchise isn't slowing
down anytime soon, as a proper threequel,
Sonic the Hedgehog 3, will drop in 2024.
Not much is known about this next entry in
the series right now. However, a tease on
Twitter announcing the film back in August 2022
suggests that both Tails and Knuckles could
be back in action alongside the eponymous
Sonic, once again voiced by Ben Schwartz.
Nobody's too sure whether Jim Carrey
will return as Dr. Robotnik, however,
as the actor has said that he is
serious about retiring from acting.
If he stands by his word,
we'll be in for a new villain,
because producers have said they
have no plans to replace Carrey in
the role. Either way, Sonic is speeding
towards release on December 20th, 2024.
First introduced in the comics as a morally
ambiguous replacement for the Avengers,
the Thunderbolts team is composed of a variety
of former villains. The MCU movie Thunderbolts,
however, will introduce a slightly different team.
Announced in 2022, Thunderbolts will act as a
culmination of multiple storylines from previous
films, featuring a cast made up of previously
seen anti-heroes. This includes Red Guardian,
Yelena Belova, Taskmaster, the Winter
Soldier, U.S. Agent, and the mysterious Ghost.
"Still fits."
They'll be led by CIA director Valentina
Allegra de Fontaine, although it remains
to be seen if Harrison Ford's Thaddeus Ross
will be a member of the team. We know Ford
will be showing up in Captain America: Brave New
World, just as we know Ross is a key member of
the Thunderbolts in the comics — but there's
been no confirmation that this character will
appear in the film just yet. Meanwhile, Walking
Dead star Steven Yeun has joined the cast too,
with all signs suggesting that he will be playing
the super-powered goliath known as the Sentry.
Directed by Jake Schreier and penned by Lee
Sung Jin, both of whom recently struck gold
with the Netflix series Beef, the film
seems poised to rock the very foundations
of the MCU. Expect to see these ragtag
heroes in action on December 20th, 2024.
Once known only as a comedian, Jordan Peele
has recently established himself as one of the
brightest writer-directors in Hollywood. Oozing
with atmosphere and filled with symbolism and
allegory, his 2017 sci-fi thriller Get Out blew
the world away with its story of a young man who
discovers a terrifying and bizarre secret after
meeting his girlfriend's family. Often exploring
themes of racism and social injustice, Peele's
films have garnered an outpouring of critical
acclaim, with follow-ups Us and Nope delivering
plenty of thrills and thought-provoking dramatics.
In 2023, it was announced that Peele's
as-yet-untitled fourth film will arrive
on Christmas Day, 2024, making it alternative
programming for big-budget blockbusters Sonic
the Hedgehog 3 and Thunderbolts. As of press
time, we don't know the genre of the film,
let alone who will star or what it will be
about. Will it be a chilling horror movie
like Us or a mind-bending sci-fi like Get Out?
Nobody knows. But one thing is for sure: This
movie will no doubt be a highly inventive project
starring some of the best actors in Hollywood;
after all, Peele remains one of the most in-demand
filmmakers currently working. While we can't say
who's involved just yet, you can make a
safe bet that Daniel Kaluuya will likely
make an appearance, as the British actor has
starred in two of Peele's three films so far.
Actor-turned-director John Krasinski is still
wowing audiences in front of the camera with
his leading role in the fourth and final
season of Jack Ryan. After that, though,
he'll be turning his attention
back to directing. In fact,
he recently announced his next film — and it's
not what you might expect from the creator of A
Quiet Place. Krasinski is mostly keeping
tight-lipped about the project for now,
but the name of the film is intriguing
enough on its own: It's titled simply IF.
IF is said to be a story about
childhood imagination. During
a presentation of behind-the-scenes
footage at CinemaCon, Krasinski said:
"I had this idea for a movie years
ago about imaginary friends."
The film's cast will be a mix of
live-action stars and voice talent,
featuring Krasinski himself and a
number of Hollywood heavyweights,
from Ryan Reynolds to Emily Blunt to Matt
Damon and more. Despite all that secrecy,
IF has already completed filming; the
movie is due for release on May 24th, 2024.